before the tower reached me before the  tower reached out to me before that was  me before the dollar reached me before  the dollar East before the dollar  reached me before the dollar reached me  before the word it's me I was a very  simple person I was a Christian atheist  I wasn't praying before about reach me I  never thought our bi Li Dao 2025  thousand subscribers with millions of  people watching my videos in over 20  countries by clicking the link below  only do you become a down movement  member you joined our movement and  inspire millions of people to accept  Islam and maybe become future dies  become a towel is remember now become a  double movement member no no become a  towel movement and by now why don't you  become 8,000 movement member now become  add our movement member today and  support us by clicking the link